The Witcher 3 is dropping its first paid
expansion next month while Bethesda are
already talking DLC plans for fall out
for and destinies of the taken King just
hit shelves while DLC packs and
expansions are fairly controversial
there are certainly some gems in the
bunch said gems range from contained
story-based dlc like left behind for the
last of us to massive expansions like
the shivering isles for oblivion or
civilization 5 brave new world there are
also content expansions like episodes
from liberty city for GTA 4 and skyrim
dragonborn which reinvigorated the
massive open worlds of skyrim and
liberty city there are too many great
expansions to mention in this video but
here are five that are among the very
best
Bioshock Infinite's burial at sea dlc
was absolutely fantastic but in the
scope of bioshock dlc it's Minerva's Den
2 Bioshock 2 that wins out Bioshock 2
may have not been everybody's cup of tea
but minerva's den seemed to universally
impress those who played it Minerva's
Den casts you in the role of an alpha
series Big Daddy the game explores
rapture central computing the home of
the thinker otherwise known as the
world's first artificial intelligence
minerva's den earned critical acclaim
for exploring its compelling themes with
expert storytelling and great writing
written by the same guy who would go on
to create gone home minerva's den has a
great story for you to unravel and it's
just as enjoyable as it was in the first
game when it comes to Mass Effect
although the citadel dlc is definitely
awesome it's not my pick for this video
I could have chosen any number of
brilliant DLC packs for the ethic RPG
series but I have to go with lair of the
shadow broker and not just because liara
with my shepherds one true love and she
had a real lonely time without her in
mass effect 2 lair of the shadow broker
only clocks in at a few hours but its
space know our story hilarious meta
banter and incredible assault on the
shadow brokers base they get a must-play
for Mass Effect fans as it seriously
evident from the elder scrolls and
fallout series but there's to really
know what they're doing when it comes to
making DLC for an open world game one of
the best examples of this is old world
blues / Fallout New Vegas old world
blues is the third add-on for new vegas
it sets the tone by having the career
abducted from a drive-in in the new
Vegas wasteland they then need to rescue
their own brain which was removed after
that whole messy abduction thing you'll
encounter lasers and robot scorpions as
well as retro futuristic characters
nuclear disasters hilarious
circumstances and more mutations than
you can shake a stim pack at another
content atom which is popular for very
good reason is tiny tina's assault on
dragon keep for Borderlands 2 it's
fairly well known that the borderlands
universe is totaling bombastic and more
than a little insane tiny tina's
expansion takes that to the next level
with spot on comedy and plenty of
outlandish developments to get you
invested in the characters and the plot
the world of borderlands and its many
inhabitants are reinvented as a figment
of tiny tina's imagination as a result
the campaign adopts a Dungeons and
Dragons style which is reflected in
enemies items and even some brand new
fantasy themed character heads in
typical Borderlands fashion the
absurdity crude humor and clever writing
of this DLC makes any tina's assault on
dragon keep absolutely worth playing red
dead redemption had absolutely nothing
to prove after gathering critical
acclaim nonetheless rockstar was still
set to impress with their DLC undead
nightmare no one anticipated that a game
lauded for its mature and serious
Western story would come out with the
DLC expansion all about shooting up Lum
bees even less of us anticipated that it
would actually be really really good
John marstons main threat shifted for
more men to the zombie plague in the
standalone adventure undead nightmare
which takes place completely separately
to that of the main game fighting off
the undead plague was a fun comedic
departure from the original game
particularly with returning characters
like Seth and the blunderbuss that uses
zombie bits for ammo because of course
it does it was a huge risk to change
gears from complex storytelling to a
pulpy zombie Rob but luckily for rock
star they totally made it work let me
know down in that comment section what's
been your favorite piece of DLC or
expansion pack and do let me know if
there's anything I missed out on I will
get you again next week